[Applause]
i'm so excited you are come join us at
the desk thank you i feel so like
intimidated because i love you so much
that's so funny i feel the exact same
way i just i love
comedians you are my medicine
you are how i get through all of it if
you have something wonderful laughter is
welcome if you have something really
dark
laughter is welcome it's how i get
through life and
actually there is a story in the news
and it was a headline that i thought
might be perfect for all of us to
discuss
ida will you please take the first story
sure
next up for anyone online dating out
there if you looked at some of these
guys profile pics and noticed something
fishy you're not wrong
the new
the new york post reports there's
actually a trend of guys posting photos
posing with fish
okay
i'm not mad at it
maybe they just want to hook up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so research looked at a hundred random
profiles in virginia of course and 42 of
them included a pig posing with a big
fish in their hands
so ross drew
what are these fish picks trying to say
and are you taking the bait
oh
taking the bait that's a rossy yeah you
know i mean i'm not mad at it i'm
surprised there are so many people
fishing but you know it shows that who
you are if you are a fisherman i just
don't think it's like i don't want to go
on a date with a fisher sorry you know
like
you know you're just going to smell like
a tuna boat you know i don't care about
that you don't oh god no not at all you
can you can in fact remember in 50 first
dates i say to adam sandler oh yeah you
do
you have the hands and you smell like
fish and
no
my biggest thing is are you nice yeah
and are you going to be nice every day
or are you going to surprise me out of
nowhere and be a monster guess what
that's what i don't want yeah i don't
trust uh anybody who performs like the
people that hold their dogs the people
that hold their fish the people with a
rainbow like i just don't trust it i
think it's performative
but it's a good way to weed them out
because you're like oh he's trash next
yeah
what would you put on your dating app
just a picture just it was just a
picture it was not like like i'm super
cool like i'm not holding a handbag i'm
not you know i didn't draw my lips on
like jennifer coolidge like i don't do
any of that i just
i just you know i just show up as me and
and that's all i can do i you know have
friends who are like hey i'm writing a
profile and they write these essays i'm
like did you write that for your college
application yeah did you put that much
effort into it uh-huh no so why are you
doing this performance all right so if
there was a picture of a guy with a fish
you would swipe yes or no
i don't know as long as he you know for
me ironically i don't want coy
[Applause]
i'm so proud of you
i am so
proud of you you are if you're a
fisherman or whatever you are just tell
me who you are yeah and if there's not a
romantic connection maybe you guys
should just be best friends
right
all right finally if you're if you're
looking to get into shape and we've got
just the news for you the good news
network reports scientists have proven
that lifting a weight for only three
seconds a day three seconds can make
your muscles grow okay i want to hear
more researchers in australia and japan
had participants do downward bicep curl
which is like that
i guess so i don't know for once once a
day for just three seconds and after a
month their muscle strength actually
grew by over 11 percent and the trick is
that needs to be heavy a
weight
using like your maximum effort and so
today
i was thinking maybe we should if we
really i have a wedding coming up girl i
gotta get my body in shape well i asked
the team what type of weights they got
us
and of course they went for the funny
because i was kind of into it i was like
listen i'll do this three seconds a day
is about
the you know that kind of commitment is
something i feel like i can do yeah but
i just want to say when we're done with
this does barbie need her weights back i
mean look at that
this is why people don't want to believe
science right now
why we have such a war on our hands
these articles
by the way i my biceps are happy though
are they yeah they are actually feel
that rossi look at look at let me see
hey wow you got guns
guns on top bags on the bottom
however
three seconds a day of anything i feel
like we could we could yes we could do
that well i can think of one thing that
i don't want to do for three seconds
[Laughter]
no it happens why are you looking at me
when you say that
i know something i could do for over an
hour and that is watch ida rodriguez
fighting words on hbo max
and if you're in the area
at the mohegan sun march 3rd through the
5th thank you so much for coming
[Music]
you